الانقلاب العسكري في القبل هو الاحدث في
سلسله من الانقلابات تشهدها افريقيا منذ
الخمسينيات
فالعديد من اساتذه العلوم السياسيه يصفون
ثوره 23 يوليو عام
1952 في مصر من انقلاب عسكري
منذ عام 1950 شهد العالم
486 محاوله انقلاب عسكري كان من بينها 214
في افريقيا وحدها
تتصدر القاره السمراء قائمه القارات من
حيث عدد محاولات الانقلاب بنسبه
44% نجحت 242 محاوله حول العالم من بينها
106 محاولات في افريقيا
شهدت 45 دوله افريقيه من اصل 54 دوله
بالقاره انقلاب عسكريا مره واحده على
الاقل
بينما يتصدر السودان القاره بسبعه عشر
محاوله انقلاب نجح منها سته ومن اغسطس
2020 الى اغسطس 2023 شهدت افريقيا 18
محاوله انقلاب عسكري نجح منها تسعه
تسعه انقلابات في سبع دول هي مالي
والسودان وغينيا وبوركينا فاسو وتادو
والنيجر
وباستثناء السودان فان الدول الست الاخرى
كانت مستعمرات فرنسيه
[موسيقى]
تختلف ظروفه سيناريوهات واسباب الانقلابات
في افريقيا من دوله لاخرى ومن وقت لاخر
لكن العوامل المشتركه هي الفقر والفساد
وسوء الاداره وضعف الديمقراطيه